what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
you know my interviewing series
um before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos today
I have a special guest on the channel
now a little a little um you know
background on how I met this special
guest I would be having shows um and I'd
be arguing with girls about things and I
this guy messaged me and he was just
like wrong
wrong that girl's saying something
that's not correct wrong wrong and he
would have the the most detailed like
stats and studies talking about why like
something someone on the show was saying
was incorrect I was like wow this guy
this guy's really smart
um so I decided to invite him on the
show on myself welcome Dr David Baker um
can you tell the people a little bit
about your background you know how how
did you get to the point where you could
just correct these women off the top of
your head
first I'll say it's really uh surreal to
hear that intro in real time
um but yeah I've been an academic uh for
about 15 years
um
been teaching at various universities
the Netherlands here in Australia uh for
12 those years
um and I've got uh three degrees PhD I'm
a doctor but not one of the real useful
ones that can you know treat cancer
and my specialist is my sorry my
specialty is uh broad Trends in natural
and human history
so that involves a lot of science a lot
of evolutionary theory but also a sort
of bird's eye view of human history uh
you know the Paleolithic
hunter-gatherers uh uh the world history
of The Agrarian period and of course uh
the the modern era
so I think uh some of the earliest
things I objected to uh were
one one lady's uh rather rose-colored
view of uh hunter-gatherers and how
everyone was just a promiscuous and
living life in some sort of hippie
commune of abundance which which is is
actually a common trope
um because if you can view uh
pre-history with rose-colored goggles
then
um you can blame all the evils of the
world with the start of Agriculture and
the start of uh sedentism and property
and land claims and so that's what's
caused all the evils of the world
um rather than something more innate in
the human character and I think the
second one I pointed out to you at the
beginning was uh sort of an equally
fallacious myth about ancient Greece and
how both men and women were just having
it on all the time in in orgies and it
being far more sexually liberated than
it actually was
and you go through this in your book
that's coming out in the fall correct
it's the shortest history of sex
and then you had another book called The
broader history of the universe
the shortest history of our universe is
is the first book the second book uh is
uh sex colon uh two billion years of
procreation and Recreation
um which was the Publisher's choice not
me and and both of these books have
different names in in different markets
for some reason okay okay
okay so tell me so you mentioned um that
people have rose-colored glasses of like
hunter-gatherer times like what do you
mean by that
uh okay
well there's sort of two major schools
of thought
with regarding
um the human character in pre-history so
one is you know hobbsian nasty brutish
short where there is no law enforcement
um there is no uh a strict society and
people are living more off their
instincts and so really our evolutionary
history should tell us a lot more about
how people behave back then
um and that's why you you get uh
statistics like a 10 murder rate if you
look at uh the the bodies of Paleolithic
corpses
um those who had died by some kind of
violence
um
roughly equates to 10 of all those
surveys and then of course there's some
more Russo
view of Paleolithic which is that of the
noble savage where Mankind's character
is pure uh he's he's a blank slate and
then all the evils of the world came in
when people started talking about land
and money
and and of course as you may guess that
that informs people's politics and I
think you can guess which side uh
different factions fall down on uh the
truth of course like most things is
somewhere in the middle
so there's a 10 murder rate back then
Paleolithic yeah uh that's probably the
number one stat that that shows that no
it wasn't all hunky dory back then
um most of it's of course interpersonal
violence we're not talking uh skirmishes
or quote-unquote Wars between tribes uh
it's just I mean you think about uh the
sort of sometimes fractured relations
between individual people today within
families and jealous lovers and so on
and so forth that was happening back
then just just as well except no police
force no forensics and most conflicts
tend to be mediated between famines and
of course vendettas were also carried
out between families as well
so when so when you say what what time
period did you say that was in
uh that was uh all of prehistory for
homesteakings so our species is
estimated to be around 300 350 000 years
old
um so that uh until about 12 000 years
ago started agriculture
okay and what changes did like
Civilization go through when agriculture
because before it was hunter-gatherer
and then 12 000 years ago it's that's
like I'm sorry if these are very low
level questions but uh is that that's
like farming
yeah it's a fair amount to unpack it
isn't low level in fact it's like the
opposite but yeah so 12 000 years ago
you're at the invention of agriculture
in one part of the world and it was
invented independently subsequently in
other parts of the world over the next 5
000 years
um and that was not pyramids or cities
or civilizations that was just small
farming communities of a few hundred
people but now suddenly uh sedentary not
nomadic spread across the world and with
that you see an explosion population uh
it's estimated that if everyone on Earth
was 100 gatherer the world could not
support more than about 8 million people
um and then of course once you have
early agriculture within a few centuries
um the population shot up to around 50
million people
and that's only with agriculture in a
few parts of the world but for about 5
000 years between the invention of
agriculture and uh the the rise of the
first civilizations there there were
just these small communities and they
might congregate in tiny Villages uh and
eventually growing to uh sort of
makeshift camps and cities usually with
religious significance of maybe a couple
of thousand
and then around let's say five thousand
five hundred six thousand years ago you
get the rise of the first city-states in
Mesopotamia and so The Agrarian period
can be split into essentially pre-city
and post City
um so 12 000 and then five thousand
years ago and The Agrarian era of course
lasted uh until about 250 years ago with
the major changes brought about by the
Industrial Revolution
and so question you said that the world
like there's a rise in population after
um
agriculture was invented
so how many kids were people having
before that because I would think they
were just popping them out with no birth
control like did did they just die like
more kids die I'm guessing or
uh in nomadic hunter-gatherers societies
um you actually have fewer kids it's in
your interest to have fewer kids but
you're right there wasn't birth control
in the sense that we have it
uh contraception
um the pill and abortion uh birth
control would be carried out mostly by
infanticide
so um
if you are a nomadic group
um you could only carry you know a
couple of infant children at a time
before it starts to slow down the group
and thoughts and danger their survival
the same also applies to the old and
infirm who would uh sometimes be
abandoned in the wild to die alone
uh so if you had that third kid let's
say uh that kid would be killed
no oh this is that's crazy so
wow so they really only had two kids
back then
uh you know more often than not one
infant at a time and then that infant
would be uh looked after until it was
old enough to be reasonably
self-sufficient on its own two feet and
then you'd be clear to have another kid
um how did how did relationships work
back then was it one I'm assuming it
wasn't monogamous
well uh there's a bit of a misconception
about that okay
so there's there's a statistic that
floats around that is frequently misused
um sometimes by the the big
quote-unquote signs channels uh where uh
they say 85
of societies that have ever existed
human cultures have ever existed were
non-monogamous now that's not quite true
they had monogamy in fact in almost all
cases that was monogamy in the majority
but uh it's only that remaining 15 that
outlawed of other things other than
monogamy
so in a typical hunter-gatherer Society
you'll have most people being monogamous
but you might see some of the elite or
some of the particularly attractive or
strong or socially prominent having
multiple whys and it was almost always
collageny multiple wise it wasn't
anything else it wasn't one wife many
men it wasn't swinging
um even in modern uh hunter-gatherer
societies uh where there is a level of
quote-unquote promiscuity it's it's a
very rigidly defined and most of it
advantages the men not the women
um so for example
this there's so many of these
promiscuous quote-unquote tribes in the
Amazon
um one of them essentially they uh the
girl is allowed to have sex and I say
girl because we're talking uh as young
as 12 or 13. we'll be allowed to have
sex uh and with any man she wants
whatever she wants but then the one who
impregnates her becomes her husband
and then some tribes have ritual dinners
where in order to defuse friction
between men because some of the men
aren't necessarily getting laid uh that
girl will have to subject herself to a
consecutive sex that is to say sex with
one man after another over the course of
an evening up to about 20 men when she's
about 12 13
um as as part of these nuptial rituals
um and a lot of this grows out of the
idea that uh fertilizer their cultural
idea that fertilization doesn't happen
from the insemination of one man's sperm
but actually you essentially fill the
tank as it were with as much sperm as
possible and then eventually the baby
pops up so I can only imagine how
terrifying it would be to be a 12 or 13
year old girl and have have sex with 20
men in an evening
um
though interestingly enough this
particular tribe whose name I cannot
remember off the top of my head uh if it
it was known if the girl resisted that
ritual she would be punished with a gang
rape she'd have to have sex with them
all at once so a lot of these
promiscuous
um hunter-gatherer rituals were very
much uh to the advantage of men and and
very much
uh
well let's not exactly your your Reddit
or Tumblr version of promiscuity swing
and the same goes for polyamory where
most of the time uh the polygony
involved was someone high status
uh
whether you know a leader of a tribe
which to be honest is sort of where
quasi-swing back to that Trend today
um with
one-third of the sexless males just to
put it crudely
um and uh you know the the Pareto
Principle
um though whether it could actually
swing back to full polygeny um
undoubtful but there is an interesting
and I know I'm talking too long but
there is an interesting thing about this
is evolutionarily we've got both the uh
monogamous and the uh polyamorous
symptoms in our in our DNA because for
40 million years most of our species
that you know we have last common
ancestry with with other primates
um on Earth
um most of those species were either
polygenous or permissions so polygenists
like gorillas or uh promiscuous like
chimpanzees
um and that involved you know a lot of
contests between Alphas or access to sex
and females
um and a lot of aggression and a lot of
men being out of luck when it comes to
reading it all and then roughly two
million years ago because of the
increase in uh brain size
and Homo erectus there was this
revolution in brain size that no doubt
contributed to an increase in our
intelligence and our abilities
uh that actually one made pregnancy much
more difficult for females
um that's where the the agonies of Labor
really came in because of this increased
head size the the uh vaginal cavity did
not increase in in within the to the
same degree so pregnancy became more
agonizing and dangerous and really
yes and incense became uh uh more
helpless for for longer
so I'm sure you've seen uh you know well
perhaps you've seen a footage of a
giraffe or a horse being born and then
they're walking within minutes of uh of
of coming out of the womb
um
that that that sort of self-reliance
that quick self-reliance was no longer
the case in our own lineage about two
million years ago so you need both
parents to look after the infant from
far longer which uh required some
collaboration between a man and a woman
so you have the evolution of the
Instinct toward monogamy
about two million years ago and here's
the thing
um
it's an imperfect instinct
because yes two million years is a long
time but so is 40 million years of
polygyny or promiscuity and so that's
why as far as monogamous mammals go and
only two to five percent of mammals are
monogamous uh we are we are not
particularly gifted at the monogamy
thing so there's a lot more infidelity
and there are impulses toward wanting to
pair up with one powerful guy or from
the guy's perspective uh sleep with a
lot of women and and the the two
instincts are a conflict in a variety of
ways when it comes to male and female
attraction
so okay the the head side that's so
interesting so we didn't have childbirth
pain before 2 million years ago
well I'm sure the the process prior to
two million years ago was painful
because you see distress from all sorts
of American species when they're giving
birth but it became
almost absurdly ill-suited
um because of the increase in in uh
brain size to the point that it vastly
endangered uh the lives of females of uh
the species in our family tree
um and yeah made it incredibly
and was that like did I put it
so two million years ago was that
were we like half monkeys then or were
we ha like I don't I don't know much
about Evolution
um Homo erectus Okay so uh we're not
we're pretty much not monkeys we we look
fairly Human by that point if you were
to shave uh Homo erectus and put them on
a bus in the middle of the day in
clothes of course uh most people
wouldn't look twice at him okay um
complex stone tools we were capable of
increasing amounts of uh uh verbal
communication uh our the range of sounds
we could have met were still fairly
limited
um but we were becoming very socially
complex by two million years ago which
is actually probably the primary cause
of the increase in frame size
so okay so two million years ago our
heads got bigger we all got smarter the
um
and before then you're saying we were
more like sexually promiscuous like that
was when it was more
the amount of uh sexual dimorphism
between species
um 2.5 and 3 million years ago across
several species would imply that we were
polygenous not promised uh promiscuous
our last common ancestor with Kim benzes
man will have been promiscuous because
chimps are more uh primitive than
poligenous but uh no that there seems to
be some consensus among uh evolutionary
anthropologists nowadays that we went
back to uh polygyny when we were
wandering the the Savannah of East
Africa okay
and was the polygyny like was it both
ways were the women's sorry if this is a
dumb question but were that were the
women sleeping with everyone and the men
sleeping with everyone or was it like
hypergamous like the women were just
with a couple Alpha guys
uh polygeny is one man many women okay
okay that's what I thought okay so then
um
and you so you're saying it's a really
misconstrued that most of like the last
two million years most of societies were
um polygymus where most of the time they
were actually most people were
monogamous but there was a couple guys
that had you know a bunch of coffee
lions and stuff
we're turning humans now yes that's the
case for the most part
um uh you know we have the impulse
towards monogamy
um it isn't perfect but we do have the
impulse as so many people in many
different societies would uh tend that
way uh and for the most part that was
all most men could manage
unless uh of course they had a lot of
money or status or whatever it might be
um with the the exception being
societies where religion mandates that
uh I'd say a man has multiple wives
apparently there's no better pickup line
than uh God wants us to sleep together
um so yeah religion being a powerful
cultural Force aside uh yes most most of
those societies were were uh the
majority of those Society individuals in
those societies were monogamous but they
permitted polygamy or polyandry or
whatever it might be
um and that's what you get the figure
for of 85 it's only more recently
um that of all things other than the
monogamy have been uh outlawed uh
roughly in the last thousand years but
further back in Europe because the Roman
Empire uh did not look too kindly on
anything that wasn't monogamy and that
was passed on to the Christian kingdoms
of Europe uh and uh then you saw this
rapid spread of uh pro-monogamy around
the world during the colonial era where
suddenly uh polygyny in in other
colleges around the world also uh sort
of they dropped the polygeny excuse me
okay and so that was that in the so a
thousand years ago so that was during
the city era it started because the
hunter-gatherer area which is twelve
thousand the city era which was like 5
500 and then the industrial area which
is 250 years the last 250. 250 Years
starting in Great Britain a thousand
years ago we're talking you know just
before William the Conqueror uh
subjugated England
so you know Middle Ages
oh Middle Ages okay okay so
how did um okay so in the
hunter-gatherer era people had like two
kids
um or they would wait until they got old
enough to
be on their own so what like 8 10
you uh you would have uh infant children
slower so you could have many children
it's just they would have to be spaced
part and of course women have a a narrow
window of fertility
um so you just as opposed to the earlier
growing era where you were sedentary and
suddenly you could just have uh five six
eight twelve in quick succession you had
to space it up when you say agree when
you say agrarian do you set this is that
the city
no let's start farming so 12 000 years
ago
um you've got sort of the early
agreement here oh so 12th sorry farming
hunter-gatherer I wrote that wrong
hunter-gatherers before 12 000 years ago
okay 350
000 to 12 000 years ago okay
and then
yeah you can still have a large family
in uh the the foraging era the
hunter-gatherer era
um but it would be much more space apart
and a lot less likely plus you know
infant mortality prior to the Monarch
modern era was uh always very very high
so if you're already having a more
limited number of kids compared to the
Neolithic or the last 5 000 years yeah
you're going to wind up with fewer kids
okay yeah cause I'm just trying to
understand like what family structures
looked like in each era
much like ours
um in in all eras in terms of the
immediate family
um unless of course we're dealing with
uh polygeny which is slightly different
but if we're dealing with the monogamous
uh culture uh predominantly monogamous
culture then you've got mothers fathers
Aunts Uncles
uh brothers sisters and a a really easy
way to conceptualize how they uh
hunter-gatherer societies ran their
um excuse me excuse the redundancy how
they ran those their societies was uh
imagine the mafia
you know Sicily coming over to the
United States uh a lot of uh disputes
are mediated between families
um a lot of discussions of claims to
forging territory settled between
families that was the immediate uh
center of gravity for all power and
negotiation in a foraging society and
then you widen the circle out to uh sort
of your local Kim group and then uh
further out to uh people who share your
cultural markers your language your
trial your gods
okay and so then
um
in the city era did people have more
children less children
uh they have more children so things
exploded after the invention of
agriculture 12 000 years ago suddenly
you were having three four five six
twelve children
um and then that remains the case for
becoming his uh the rest of human
history what you could call conventional
human history until uh very recently
when birth rates have gone into the
toilet sort of starting
uh 20th century okay and so why is that
what changed
why have birth rates gone into the
toilet yeah
oh okay
um well there already seems to be a
transition in the modern era
um at the start of the 20th century
uh where uh essentially you've got a few
um
uh obstacles uh to to women uh
essentially
um having uh other things to do other
than being a a a wife and mother
so uh one of course is financial
dependence and for the longest time most
women and I have to of course qualify
that this is generalizations there are
so many exceptions in the 19th century
and and indeed any period
um but most women of course are go from
Financial dependence on her father to
her husband
um prior to the modern era uh around
about the 1920s it became increasingly
uh common in the developed world so the
West uh later being joined by countries
like Korea and Japan
uh it became increasingly common from
1920s onwards for these girls to to move
out of their father's place before uh
they uh got married and they work a job
as a waitress or whatever it might be
and they'd share a flat with uh other
women and suddenly that that allowed
them to to be more promiscuous and you
do see a a mark increase in the rate of
premarital sex in that period
um but also it gives them uh
opportunities to do other thing with
other things with that rather narrow
biological window where they're fertile
so you know late teens 20s 30s
um up to 35 before geriatric pregnancy
and
um
so you have that a slight dip in birth
rates starting in the 1920s and then the
1930s because of the depression people
were just having Hero Kids generally
because you're not going to bring kids
into the world when you're you're
struggling
um the baby boom after the war uh wasn't
a case of people having tons of kids per
family that was that mostly it was
people having two kids you'd already
arrived at the nuclear family by then
um but more people were getting married
at that point after the war
and uh but then once you have the the
introduction of various forms of
contraception
um and from 1960 19 and 1970 you have a
vast surge of women into the workforce
that is pretty much what uh put the nail
into the coffin of the birth rate a
particularly the workforce thing it's
not the pill like many people think
because Japan is one of the first
countries to nosedive demographically
and the pill was illegal in Japan until
uh 1999. it's actually just the sheer
Act of of women it becoming the cultural
norm for women to go from high school to
University or whatever post-secondary it
might be and pursue the career uh and of
course if you're building your career
during your 20s your focus even if you
want to get married at the same time
your focus still is split between family
and career which means you're spending a
lot of your time which could be spent uh
finding a husband having children
um to uh working on that career and
pursuing other opportunities which does
reduce uh the amount of children you can
have significantly also pushes back the
the average age of first child
significantly
um simply by identity the fact that
you've got a lot of other stuff going on
in your life and and that seems to be
the sole uh the soul
Factor when it comes to the the drop in
in the birth rate in the 1970s
so interesting I didn't realize that
birth rates were going down to in the
1920s
the birth rate started really high at
the start of the 20th century and it's
progressively dropped since then it's
the the decline in the birth rate seems
to be a symptom of uh the modern era of
industrialization
um and and the sort of growth of living
standards and career opportunities
generally for both men and women
and when you said um like there was an
increase in promiscuity like I saw a
stat because I wanted to know um like a
hundred years ago what percent of women
were like virgins on their wedding days
and it was still like I mean you know
you can't possibly know right I mean
they could have lied but but it was
still like like I think 80 percent would
didn't admit to premarital sex in the
20s
yeah that's that's true
um uh 80 sounds about right I actually
give the the reliable stat in my book
um I can't tell you what it was in the
20s off the top of my head or or the 20
uh the early 20th century but here's
here's the distinction we need to make
social class so one will make the
distinction that we're talking about the
the Western the industrialized World
um if you're not industrialized yet
you're still stuck to agrarian patterns
and most of the world would still follow
the traditional patterns as a lot of the
world still does
um but the other thing to consider is
lower class women in in uh
industrialized countries particularly
cities were very promiscuous even in the
the 19th century
okay
um and upper class women
[Music]
upperclassified
um we're also fairly promiscuous but for
slightly different reasons
um generally speaking they had that
economic cushion that they were able to
engage in Liaisons but if you want to
get a good uh a barometer of of where
women were at sexually you look at the
middle class one because she tends to be
the the most morally stodgy
and upright and let's face it judgmental
so you need to look at what percentage
of middle class women were having
premarital sex to really get a a clear
idea of where that's so interesting yeah
because it's kind of like in society
today the upper class like like the sex
parties the rich people have you know
like the the celebrities they always
find out that the celebrities are doing
weird [__] you know these open marriages
or whatever so you're totally right it
doesn't represent women it's the same
thing with the lower class women I never
thought about looking at middle class
how did you even find that Stacks I'm
like how would you even know
that there are a few interesting
academic surveys written throughout the
the 20th century so none of them were
really covered the whole period but you
can Cobble together the stats the only
thing you have to allow for is the the
perhaps slight inaccuracies
um when it comes to people lying
um like and you would get that from both
upper and lower class women in the early
20s centuries of course they wouldn't
mind when it comes to the lower class
they're not doing sex parties so much as
um there's less riding on their
virginity because they're already dirt
poor so they might as well have fun you
know um go to the pub throw back a
couple of gyms and have a bit of a
fumble and an alleyway
um that uh by a middle class family
suddenly yes there's still that material
wealth that's dependent on these the
these sexual mores that sexual
self-discipline the same is true of
upper class families but you do see
slightly less uh sexual discipline in
upper class women because they're rich
and they can get away with functionally
they wouldn't all be at it right there
would be a decent level of uh of
virginity and discipline in say another
class
family in in the 1910s
um but it would be lower than middle
class women
who have all the pretensions of the
upper class but none of the resources
um yeah so there are there are some
useful surveys and that's why you can
also go to the middle class and when it
comes to them lying I understand that
you have to take this with a grain of
salt but at the same time the general
trend is toward more people having
premarital sets right so they're not
going to lie about that and that's the
shift that happens throughout the 20th
century to the point that there's
already a good chunk of people who are
already having premarital sex uh during
the 40s you know the squeaky clean 1940s
and 50s weren't that spooky really okay
tell me tell me more about that the 40s
and 50s weren't because I think a lot of
times we look at like the 70s as like
the the root of all evil in society like
that was when [__] went downhill you
think that's historically accurate
it's the 70s are the culmination of
trends that were happening ever since
the war
okay um so so one uh as I already
pointed out the the cultural trend of
telling women that you need to go and
have a career
um that that started after the war
um and grew louder and louder to the
point that uh the number of couples that
had a woman at home by 1970 the year
1970 had already dropped to 40 percent
it hasn't even dropped that much since
then comparatively uh because I think
we're only sat at a 20 20 right now you
still have stayed home loans or 20 of
couples around couples wait um 1940 it
was what say that again
oh 1970
um only 40 of women were stay-at-home
wives yeah and it's just prior to the
the the demographic collapse
um
what was it in the 20s
in the 20s it was considerably higher
there was sort of in the 20th century uh
I I have to look to to remember the
decade but in the early 20th centuries
you had a high water mark of about 85 of
couples being
um married
the people who were cohabitating they
they were 85 percent
um and and had sorry uh one sorry I had
a woman working at home I started living
at home and uh uh a man going out and
provide okay okay so it went from 15 to
percent and then the 70s it was 40 or
only 40 of women were doing it
so 85 stay-at-home mothers early in the
20th centuries and already by 1970 it
had dropped to 40 and then it's dropped
to 20 now in these in the states it's 25
but I think that's uh because there
there are a lot more
um conservative religious peoples in the
in the states than there are in other
Western countries generally speaking
okay
a a die-hard traditionalist trend in the
states compared to say Australia or the
UK
Okay so
so the 70s was more of a culmination of
trends that was already happening
yeah yeah
um so
during the war and after the war
pre-marital sex
um Affairs of all kinds
were already uh in being now you could
you could say that that might be related
to
the existential threat of the war and
then the relief that the war was over
um people were throwing caution to the
wind and social mores out the window you
saw the same thing after the first world
war the only thing that put the brakes
on it was The Depression
and and suddenly risking getting
pregnant didn't seem like such a good
idea
um and and of course the same thing
happened after the second world war and
then during the 60s you had the gradual
introduction of uh various forms of
contraception also the normalization of
say condoms which started in the war
um
good luck getting a condom in 1910 let's
put it that way in most countries in the
west they do actually you couldn't
um so never mind the pill
and then in the the second world war we
started handing out condoms to GIS
because we thought it would be better if
uh you know we're not going to stop them
from from having sex so it would be
better if we Supply them with some form
of protection
um and then of course you had the birth
control contraception Revolution
throughout the 1960s
um the pill wasn't suddenly uh the big
thing in the 60s most sex was not
happening with any form of uh
contraception at that site uh that sort
even condoms weren't that condom uh
excuse me
um it was it was only in the 1970s that
the pillow really came into Vogue and
even then its impact is was fairly
overstated
um it's only more recently in say the
90s that you see this this real critical
mass of numbers
but not so the 60s and 70s it took a
while
okay it says in the 90s okay and what
impacts did that have in society so we
see the birth rate plummet
um
we see I guess Traditional Values
deteriorate
um
what yeah what what what impacts did
that have on society and like what
future Trends are we headed towards
hmm
okay
um well
how did it impact Society I mean there
are there are so many different ways in
which it did I mean we don't call the
1960s the sexual Revolution for nothing
um but okay like you have the collapse
of uh the the birth rate in the 1970s to
around replacement level or below and
it's it's just been heading down and
down and down you have the rise of
divorces
um and then the gradual decline of uh uh
marriage rates to the point that they're
we're having uh about half as many
weddings today as we were in 1970.
um the birth rate has remained fairly
stable
uh sorry the the divorce rate has
remained fairly stable since the
1990s when it sort of hit its its low
water mark but that's just because fewer
people getting married at all
um demographically we've been in the
toilet to the point now one of the major
threats to developed Nations
is uh aging societies first within a
generation or two
um you and I are going to be retiring
with a crumbling infrastructure to
support senior citizens because there
aren't going to be enough young Nippers
whipper sniffers to to pay the taxes to
actually pay for our upkeep
um and that that's a major crisis
staring uh every uh industrialized and
even industrializing society that is
slowing population growth in the face
um but I I think if you were to to
characterize the impact of what happened
in the 1970s with one statistic
it would be uh what's called the
involuntary childlessness rate
which is uh let's discount the The
Fairly consistent percentage of
population who don't want kids for
whatever reason that might be
um and uh there are a multitude of
reasons some trivial and selfish some of
them sound pretty good
um depending on their individual
standards as circumstances all right
um but if you eliminate that from the
population today
uh of all adults uh there is a 20 to 35
percent involuntary childlessness rate
um in developed Nations and it's 20 to
35 depending on the nation in question
so a country like Korea is absolutely
slammed
um but across across the the developed
world there's these adults who haven't
gotten it together to have a family and
probably never will whether that's
because they haven't got things together
romantically or because they've they've
Fallen a foul of fertility they've left
it too late and they're struggling and
of course if you look at the failure
rate of IVF and fertility treatments you
don't care about that much because well
they're hardly going to advertise it but
it's it's devastating what the failure
rates are at various ages
um so yeah 20 to 35 today they want kids
but they're probably not going to have
them which you can think about the the
toll that would exact in human misery
um where sorry you're done
my dog
Kevin Samuels right so 20 to 35 of
adults today in the west and westernized
societies
um want kids but they're probably never
going to have them because they either
waited too long or they
they're struggling the fertility it all
comes down to waiting too long um
essentially waiting too long
yeah once you hit 30
once you hit 30 is a one statistically
uh let's say you're single and 30. um
statistics your chances of carrying even
one child to term have already dropped
below 50 just because of the the average
time it would take for you to foster a
committed relationship the odds of that
one working to the point of marriage in
children plus the gauntlet you have to
run with with uh uh
fading fertility in your Navy in your
30s really so okay wait I want to repeat
that back just so I understand it so if
you get to 30 as a woman and you're
single your chance of carrying one child
the term is less than 50 percent
drops below 50 percent first time at age
30. bang on
okay
and
so what so okay so let's say we we don't
have enough kids that we have an aging
population like what what happens to
society are we is everyone going to die
they're going to be famine like what do
you I mean just based on like what's
happened I'd imagine this has never
happened historically it's historically
unprecedented
um throughout 300 000 years of human
history yeah
so
it's difficult to predict but uh of
course I've mentioned the Perils of
Aging populations
um where we're going to have a
retracting cat's face uh but to be
honest
um immigration in the west has massed
shrinking populations for quite a few
years you don't see that in Japan
because Japan refuses to increase its
quota of immigration or let uh give more
people citizenship
so uh really it's been interesting where
we've had an increased number of people
in the workplace since the 70s which has
depressed uh wage growth for the last 50
years making it increasingly difficult
for a family to uh survive on a single
income
um but that problem would have
immediately corrected itself because of
the decline in the birth rate and you
would have had a labor shortage in uh
the 90s or 2000s let's say which would
have brought wages up again but then
what governments decided to do in the
80s and 90s was uh
fairly significantly increased in
Immigration rates at that time to
compensate the fact that we weren't
having kids anymore
um and so that has that's good news for
the government because it keeps that tax
place growing
um and uh it's also good news for large
companies and employers because you know
they're keeping
um wages depressed uh because they're
sending off a labor shortage
it's it's rather bad for the average
person's standard of living
um where it's it's becoming increasingly
more difficult with every generation to
buy a house or to start a family then it
was say compared to the 1950s and 1960s
so what do you think about because like
I always hear that the it's like we
can't afford what we used to right like
I've heard that or we can't
um you know buy a house and do all these
things but it seems like in a way the
standard of living has gone up because
you know we have you know it's like we
like my dad um grew up without air
conditioning now okay not in the UK
they're crazy here but in the U.S
everybody has air conditioning and even
like poor people almost have a higher
standard of living than people used to
in a way
um would you say that's true or like
false
the poorest person in the west today
lives better than a king 500 years ago
right um and so it is a matter of uh
comparison and perspective
so
um thanks to innovation technology uh
things that used to be like trees are
now
um more commonplace we now enjoy
conveniences conveniences that would
have been unheard of even 50 years ago
and so various things have become
cheaper and also as a corollary of that
people's expectations have grown but far
beyond just the Improvement in
technology people seem to be more
aspirational and seem to be demanding
more for that basic life than they would
have done 50 years ago so it's still
relatively easy to raise a family
um provided you you make sacrifices and
and you know it's not terribly expensive
even today to clothe and feed a kid but
you're gonna have to make compromises
and increasingly we're making as as
generalization as uh as a just as a
culture where we're less willing to make
those compromises
um even as uh the real wage becomes
increasingly depressed you know I don't
want to have a kid because I want to buy
my Louis Vuitton handbag you know
well as a dental hygienist maybe you're
not in that income bracket or or I want
to raise a family but I can't afford the
rent of my apartment well maybe you
shouldn't be living in New York I know
it's stylish but maybe you're not in
that income bracket right um so it is a
matter of perspective both in terms of
what is available to us in comparison to
past Generations but also in terms of
people the shifting goal posts of
people's standards as to what is
acceptable the the comfortable living
before it would even be possible to have
a family because yeah you you can you
can be dirt poor and you can raise a
couple of kids it's not not easy of
course it isn't easy but of course you
can do it
so it's people's like standards and what
they like think is required to raise a
kid has gone up but the wages haven't
gone up to meet those
It's a combination of all of the above
so uh the people will have some sort of
threshold where they want to be able to
afford a b and c before they'd be
willing to have kids and it seems to be
the trend that that that threshold has
increased
um before they're willing to make the
the leap but at the same time in
fairness to everyone
it is it is objectively more difficult
to raise a family on a single income
today than it was 50 years ago no
question
is there any
is there any solution to that because it
seems like it's it's like you question
what the solution is because you know
maybe it's like women like living with
their parents until they get married
that seems like that would make more
sense but it's like
the girls in the meantime it's like we
have to eat you know you know what I
mean so um I guess the question is do
you think like getting married young is
the solution to this like women not like
what
I don't know I guess what would make
Society better just from a historical
perspective
okay well I mean there are historical
presidents um if you were just to tell
people to get married young it would be
a [__] disaster because if you look
at divorce rates just on service
um the divorce rates are really high for
people who marry young but you have to
look at the context in which they're
getting married which is they're both
trying to get careers off the ground and
very often they're winding up as very
different people by the time they end
their post-secondary education
so the I mean there are a number of
things that could be done and none of
them are difficult but there needs to be
actually a a social and cultural impetus
for any of this to happen
um but a lot of problems would be solved
regarding the birth rate regarding
misery and voluntary childlessness even
male sexlessness even the the
catastrophic percentage of women who in
their 30s and 40s are going to be
singling childless by mid-century
um a lot of this could be fixed by the
the simple uh cultural shift
to stop telling women young women that
they are a piece of [__] unless they
become Sheryl Sandberg that they need to
go out immediately after high school and
get a career because that and not for
ideological reasons not even for
religious reasons or anything it flies
in the face of basic biology is the
reason
um right now and for the last two or
three generations it's been the commonly
accepted Credo that your 20s are for
your career and to quote unquote find
yourself and your 30s late 20s early 30s
then you get serious about family
you're you're starting to get serious
about family when 90 of your eggs are
dead
so maybe not such a good plan
if you reverse fatigue the simple ask of
reversing the two
um so find a decent stable partner
um which is a different sort of mate
selection than it would be for just
looking for a guy who gave you that
spark in your 20s
um find that guy in your 20s start a
family and then consider the career
thing in your 30s now here's the thing
if you get married and have that first
kid in your early 20s or your mid-20s
then by your early 30s to mid 30s
perhaps even late 30s if we're being
generous
um
your eldest kid is going to be able to
reheat a few dinners in the microwave
um and perhaps even look after the
younger siblings irrespective of child
care which will still exist
um they'll be able to do that by your
mid 30s while you're staying late at
class or your
um uh staying late at the office
uh and and so you can to to confront the
old Paradox that's faced women
um you can have it all but you just got
to reverse the order of operations
um for your 20s and 30s
and uh then you know like if you think a
career is going to fulfill you
existentially you can still do it in
your 30s and you still got over a
quarter of a century to pursue whatever
field you need to now a number of
qualifications there if you need to work
of course you have to work to pay the
bills as a single person or or as a
married couple if if uh both people need
to work then they have to work that's
fair enough if you've got a particular
Talent OR passion let's say you're a
really good actress or painter or
musician obviously that's not going to
the the social worries of the day
whatever they are that stuff so by all
means go on and and launch that career
we'll we'll all be delighted for you I'm
sure but as for
the the overwhelming majority of people
who do not become uh Philharmonic
violinists who do not become corporate
Titans they don't become Sheryl Sandberg
they go to university and then they wind
up in some [__] nine to five job as
as working as a receptionist or whatever
it might be
um you know maybe running the increased
risk of winding up alone in
childlessness and childless isn't worth
that to you
um you know like if you say you have a
passion for uh art or you have a passion
for philosophy or literature fine if you
say you have a passion for corporate
finance I don't [__] believe you
so maybe consider that you could still
you could still pursue that high-powered
career
um if you have the family first and then
you're not going to find people wanting
to have kids and not being able to have
them because I left it too late the
birth rate goes up a lot of things
change uh and and also even the the
phenomena of of all these women chasing
uh you know narcissists and and
borderline sociopaths won't happen
because the pressure will be on to find
someone who actually would be supportive
of them early on as opposed to the
switch they make after the Epiphany
phase in their 30s so we push that up
further everyone benefits men and women
just by that simple switch in the order
of operations
yeah you said women chasing after
narcissistic men tell me more about that
well uh I mean I think you've also
discussed this on your show before about
how
there are quite a few women who are
attracted to dark Triad traits this is
not an accident this goes well back into
our evolutionary history where
um man or woman is a potentially good uh
survival Advantage if you are a a
sociopath or A congenital psychopath
um to a certain extent there's a bell
curve right so if you are too
Psychopathic you're going to be exiled
from your your community and perhaps
straight up killed okay your genes are
wiped from the gene pool on the other
side of that bell curve if you're too
much of an altruist you're a doormat
you're equally likely to be taken
advantage of enslaved killed
um that's not good either most people
cluster towards the center but it is
still for some individuals a good uh
survival strategy and has been far
beyond even homo savings to be a little
bit further on the the sociopathic end
of things when we're talking about
working our way through the forest you
know knife between our teeth we're not
talking about modern society yes
um for both men and women
a lack of empathy might be a good thing
when it comes to concerns your own
Survival and that's particularly true
for men so if you consider you live in a
world in a Paleolithic with a 10 murder
raise
um as a woman maybe shacking up with the
vaguely Psychopathic guy
is a good strategy provided he doesn't
turn his aggression toward you or your
children right
um so that that does have an
evolutionary lineage particularly when
you look at pre-monogamy
um most sexual Congress was extremely
brutal and and males of various primate
species are extremely aggressive and
horrible
um
so that
that does translate to some extent to
modern day
um to many uh
surface level
sexual choices and and even fantasies
and fetishes so yes the the vaguely
narcissistic and sociopathic guy as a
woman might be attractive in a very
visceral sense
um but he's also the guy who's probably
going to ghost you or probably going to
waste three years of your narrow window
in your 20s
um jerking you around but not putting a
ring on it
um there are risks with with going for
for the the narcissist and the sociopath
as well what do you what do you think of
um
like Rollo um has a term where he says
like five minutes of alpha um trumps a
lifetime of beta and basically basically
saying that like once a girl has had a
so-called Alpha like she can't go down
or if she does she's always gonna like
want the guy she was with before I think
he calls it like an alpha Widow like
like in the Titanic you know
um that old lady is still talking about
Jack it's been like
and you know there's so many like movies
where it's like same with the notebook
she goes back to her High School
boyfriend
yeah and and it's the foundation of most
bodice rippers as well
um
bodice rippers the the old pulp books
that that the romance books that that
women used to buy off of the the rack at
the grocery store oh wow
well this might this goes back to like
the 80s but yeah you know the picture of
the long-haired Fabio guy
um very trashy romance novels borderline
pornographic
oh that's the foundation for all of
those they call them bodice rippers
which is basically
um a a faux resistant woman is
overpowered by The Dashing broke or
whatever this is this there's a strong
impulse this
um
when it comes essentially like roll is
absolutely right
um and and what it comes down to and
it's undeniable and and it's too bad for
anyone who's any guy who's sort of like
your conventional well-meaning guy with
his his office job and his pair of
khakis it's just a nice decent guy and
he wants to date conventionally is is
female sexuality as a general rule of
course there are many individual
exceptions but as a general rule tends
to be more excited by by the Rogue or
the the alpha or to be honest the
narcissist or borderline sociopath tends
to be more excited by that assuming
there's an equivalent degree of physical
attractiveness
um then they would be
um uh excited in the same way by a a
someone who would make a good stable
partner
um that's not to say women don't find uh
the latter group attractive it's just in
a very different way
a very different way and that's what
leads to the phenomenon of uh the alpha
Widow and yeah so
okay so you would say that is true
uh yes that was my 120 word response to
to your question like because he would
always say um like Rolo would I'm just
curious like from a historian's point of
view like Rolo would always say like a
woman that makes you wait for sex is
never worth the wait because she's
probably like in modern times she's
probably given it up to a different guy
like sooner
um so he he would always say that you
don't want to have like transactional
sex with a girl
well I mean if you look back to uh
pre-modern who are who are the the the
guys that
um fathers were warding off their
daughters you know they weren't all
yeah sorry go ahead
these were probably you know like they
weren't all sexual predators they
weren't all Snakes in the Grass they
weren't necessarily immoral in a lot of
cases these men were likely just men who
were sexually attracted attractive and
and their daughters were attracted to
them but even back then these cads
um had options and so they they might be
less likely to marry and so the security
system back then was well no dad's gonna
point a shotgun at you if you come by
our house again
um you don't have that fail safe anymore
right
so so the the foxes very much get in a
hen house foundation and and uh the
people who suffer for It ultimately are
the women
right well and the men that get a wife
that's like been with all these dudes
before right because
imagine eventually like if women get
married it's to the guy they see the
long-term security with
yeah provided the guys that are lucky
enough to get that far that he gets one
of those
right
so like how how does
how do you see people are dating in the
Modern Age like
um because I would imagine like this is
the first era where sex tends to come
before relationships or did that happen
before too
well I mean it depends on how you define
era
um that has become increasingly common
since the end of the last war
um premarital sex in the 50s even was
you know it was it was Taboo in some
communities but it was basically a
byword and that's why you have a lot of
even popular entertainment features that
sort of thing
um it was much more innocent compared to
today
um in the 1950s you didn't sit down
Peggy Sue and ask her what her fetishes
were but
um yeah so really like the the last half
century last seven years that's been
fairly common
um what has been the more radical shift
I think because pre-marital sex has
always been a thing throughout human
history
um we just kept it on the down low but
what has been the remote the more
radical change in recent years is is the
rise of uh
coupling via uh the internet and uh
creating apps and social media
um the average I have a great statistic
and I'm gonna butcher it but it's in the
book
um where in the 1920s the average woman
would marry a guy who lives no more than
like three or four miles away from her
um you know very much uh she would be
very much
kept to tour local community now she can
increase that radius up thousands of
miles if she wants
um and then as that has had a fairly
devastating effect on uh the sort of
balance and distribution of mates uh
amongst the sexual Marketplace which is
What's led to the the rise of uh the
increase of sexless males and also the
rise of of uh females who get jerked
around because they're all chasing the
same guy
because like what oh because they're
chasing guys in different cities now so
it's like the same it becomes a smaller
and smaller percentage of guys
I mean to just put it as simply as
possible everyone is now accessible to
everybody
right
yeah
a profound change and it's led us back
to this state of almost quasi-polygyny
um it will never be full polygeny
because you know maybe one or two women
might be willing to share a guy
um and you know maybe you might come
across the odd woman with a [__] main
fetish but for the most part women
aren't going to submit themselves to to
being you know in a her a harem of one
guy in the general population the first
of all culturally that has we've not
we're not anywhere near that yet in the
mainstream and and second of all uh even
instinctually we've got two million
years of monogamous instinct to reckon
with it's imperfect but it's still there
so you're unlikely to see reversions in
like some sort of gorilla uh types
thousand years but uh you do see the
trend in that direction where it's like
de facto we're living in religion you
know where uh you know take your pick
call it 10 uh 15 20 men are are having
sex with 60 70 80 percent of women
um at least in the dating period in your
20s before things start to get serious
Women quote unquote said
how do you how do you know it's that
high because that's always like the
the the pushback I get on the show is
that like it's it's a larger percentage
of men that you think it's not like
dating apps don't tell you everything
um how do you know it's that high well
I'm 15 of men are sleeping with 60
percent of women
yeah like the fact is dating apps are
the the majority way people are meeting
now now that Trend could change
immediately because you used to get
people getting increasingly pissed off
with dating apps right because this
trend going around right now and of
course it's not gonna catch on where you
sit in a bar and you wear some stupid
ring on your finger and it's supposed to
signal that you're you're single and you
won't call them a creep if they approach
you I don't see attaching on
um but in a few articles about that but
the thing is yes it is the most common
way but it is not the majority way at
least not from the statistics I've seen
yet it's not over 50 yet it's pretty
damn close but it's not there yet
um so that the the imbalances is created
certainly can be exaggerated by dating
app but that's not the only place where
accessibility accessibility has
increased right it's not like with the
rise of Tinder came uh the Pareto
Principle you had that in the 90s you've
had that in the 80s
um and that is a direct result of uh
increased promiscuity and and sex for
pleasure and and that's there's no way
other way around it if everyone's out
um uh sort of in a free-for-all being
able to select mates not for uh a
serious life Prospect but even just for
an exciting Affair or you know someone
who immediately sets off that spark when
you first meet him which by the way
shouldn't necessarily be a prerequisite
because it doesn't happen as often as
you'd think
um but if if that that is our our
Benchmark that's our standard that's our
starting point then by sheer mathematics
if you if you have a fairly good idea of
the distribution of male attractiveness
um it's
mathematically it's going to see women
gravitate towards the that that
because if women find 80 percent of men
is unattractive like I've seen that stat
it's like who are if if they're not
dating for like relationship or marriage
you know because now people don't really
get married
um
statistic comes from dating apps but I
just wanted to point out that that is
also substantiated by other studies
sociological studies where you survey
women in a more controlled environment
same bloody thing
yeah and this is also evolutionary uh
that that
women most women find most men
physically unappealing
that's that's actually that is something
that goes back 40 uh million years
roughly
um that if if you're looking at a
primate species that is not monogamous
which most primate species aren't
um there there are really are just a
minority of men who are physically
appealing that uh the the the females of
the species will just give it up for
them
um sexual intercourse because
genetically they're just obviously
um uh going to to lead to to the healthy
offspring
um this becomes a little more
complicated in the great apes
um so chimpanzees
um and gorillas
the uh because then social status
increasingly uh also plays a role in
female main selection but again the
increase overwhelmingly the women are
going to give it up for the higher
status males uh rather than than the
lower sales ones that this goes back a
long way the idea that most dudes you
know when it just comes to Baseline
physical attractiveness
um and The Limited number of men who can
be high status most dudes are [__] out
of luck in that respect and then that's
that's not just culture that's a cruel
fact of nature
okay so essentially
there's a percentage of men that don't
and I just want to make sure I get this
right it's kind of like they don't
really have a choice like they have to
accept transactional sex
yes yeah because
and you know what that sounds horrible
um but
ultimately it depends on what your goals
are
um you know just stepping back from
modernity for a second
um if if your goal isn't getting laid by
a bunch of different women but you just
want some companionship in the family
well then obviously that transactional
thing is beneficial to you the only
problem is modernity introduces
all of these complicating factors which
destroy that uh modernity what does that
mean
uh so just just the the trends of the
last 50 years let's say so increased
divorce rates
um uh and of course the phenomenon of
the alpha Widow and so forth that
destroys
uh what the the the goal that these men
would seek from transition uh
transactional sex right because then
it's like if the women are cheating with
their ex-boyfriend from college
yeah 100 years ago you would be able to
keep that family that would be your
family structure and you you have fairly
good probability you'd be able to feel
fairly confident
but the difference
yeah whereas now uh that that guy who
wants the family and is willing to to to
pay the beta bucks as it were
um he's he's he's gambling at an
increasingly Rich table where where that
that is less likely to pay off because
you're going to land that family you're
gonna land that outfit oh and she is
going when that family is going to be
destroyed hell she doesn't even need to
be an alpha Widow and she's financially
incentivized to walk away from Marriage
at any time so you're essentially
dependent on uh your wife's uh effusion
of feeling for you and
very rarely do do the passions of Love
Remain intense Beyond say eight years 12
years
really
yes and also again evolutionary
um because that probably not
coincidentally is roughly the same
amount of time it takes to rear a child
to basic self-sufficiency in the wild
about 12 years
where the kid obviously a 12 year old
might be screwed if he was alone in the
forest but at least it has a Fighting
Chance
so the idea that love as an instinct
keeps men and women together for an
average of eight years probably isn't a
coincidence
oh so marriage it's like marriage got
what do you call it
it's like before the men were at least
promised even if I have transactional
sex like she's not going to leave
because like you can't get out of
marriage but now since like the
introduction of like no fault divorce
and like a system that's rigged against
men it's not really as good of a deal
because she can just leave at any point
yeah there's a Confluence of factors
where yes suddenly that gamble does not
pay off for those those men who aren't
just out there being a womanizer yeah
it's it's not paying off as it would
have uh 100 years ago but from a
Confluence of factors so what oh yeah so
could you talk about men getting screwed
over in divorce like a guy a guy getting
married today like what is his chance of
you know getting completely screwed in
divorce
okay well we're probably mostly aware
that you know 45.5 as an average Cross
of developed Nations divorce rate
um now some of those divorces will of
course be the result of
um an abusive situation and we have the
statistics for that
um although it's becoming increasingly
difficult to parse that because we're
widening the the definition of abuse to
include things that perhaps
shouldn't be considered abuse like we're
not talking physical we're talking uh
did they have an argument raise his
voice
um but you know we have some Fairly
reliable statistics for divorces to
happen because of abuse we have Fairly
reliable statistics for adultery Fairly
reliable statistics for abandonment that
is to say he left his family to live
with a stripper in Vegas
um so those three things adultery abuse
abandonment being an actual breach of
the marriage contract uh once you
eliminate those uh statistics
um and he also eliminate the 10 uh to 20
of marriages that are triggered by men
for various reasons
and once you bear down on the the number
of divorces where the man
uh the reasons given are either vague or
uh seem to be fairly trivial the reason
for the divorce
um the
uh
if you look at those numbers those
divorces that seem to to not have a
clear reason
um beyond that just they didn't want to
be together anymore
um and of course we we have statistics
for uh why divorces happen very detailed
breakdowns of lists and usually there
are multiple factors that are all a sign
of percentage
um and this has been done by different
institutions for years so the
percentages vary
uh but uh once you you look at the men
who aren't given access to the children
or seem to be penalized financially to
an unreasonable degree and that is an
assumption and a judgment call you have
to make for yourself looking at the
statistics right so
um it depends on your interpretation
which will make things shift about a
little bit but once you put all those
factors together you arrive at somewhere
between 30 and 39 40 percent of these
divorces being either punitive or
malicious
um on the part of the woman that is to
say she is wielding the legal system
like a bludgeon for reasons best known
to herself
um to to uh
destroy a man's life so out of out of 10
divorces that happen four are they seem
to be
like malicious
I would I would say closer to three but
that's still a hell of a lot three to
four right right where where you know if
you marry a woman
um you've got a 50 50 shot of it
um working out or not and so cut that 30
in two if we're including the other half
which are successful marriages you've
you've got uh uh of
fairly decent chance that your divorce
is going to be reasonably Equitable that
is to say you're not going to have your
life destroyed you're still going to be
you're not going to get your kids as a
man you know highly unlikely you're
going to get 50 50. that's such a tiny
percentage of cases
um but you're not going to be absolutely
devastated
um but in most Western countries
um when that divorce thing happens that
your ex-wife will not destroy your life
out of the goodness of her own heart if
she wants to she can do that at a whim
and you are completely vulnerable
um and it's it seems to be about 30 of
such divorces seem to be done for
punitive or malicious reasons
um and and and the fact is it shouldn't
be surprising that the percentage is
that high because you're getting
divorced that woman doesn't like you
anymore she might have a clear uh
Vendetta against you
um and that seems to be uh the case for
30 mind you uh this is all just
calculation on the back of an envelope
making many assumptions along the way
but I would say even if it were 20
percent
that's still far too much where where
someone's life is being destroyed you're
you're financially killing them and
making them a a paying spectator in
their children's lives
um just because of the by then to the
bias of support system you could wield
it as a weapon
um so
so out of 10 divorces three are
malicious
um what out of the ten maybe one of the
guys gets custody of his kids maybe one
ten percent uh well it I mean okay I
mean 50 50 is pretty low like I think 50
50s somewhere between six and ten
percent really it's only six to ten
percent of guys get 50 50 custody
uh I would have to check my numbers on
that but like half the time
um in divorces the kid uh sorry the guy
is either voluntarily voluntarily
surrendering custody rights you might
get visitation and and uh in that same
half of that side of the place uh he's
he's barely getting visitation at all
like he might not get any or he might
get it like once a month or something
like so insignificant amounts of
visitation time so 50 50. right like in
many jurisdictions 50 50 is the Baseline
within statute but it rarely is that in
practice
and out of the time like what are on how
many are on child support
child support is awarded
wow
eight out of ten I'm on child support
wow divorces
awarded by the courts but the the woman
might choose not to collect but I mean
that doesn't necessarily mean that's a
large percentage of the women decide not
to collect
um and then there there are a number of
jurisdictions where the man may not pay
or may not pay in full
so if you take that into account maybe
like 60 of of divorce women receive with
with children underage children receive
some form of financial support from
their husband at some time some of it
crippling some of it not
um alimony I'm glad to see is going the
way of the dinosaur that's a very 19th
century Antiquated idea last time I
checked women were able to work
um
so and then out of the the ones that do
get married
um that like the the 10 marriages so
then the 10 like let's say we have 10
people that stay married do you have any
idea like what because the other
question I have is like what percent are
gonna get married and are gonna get
divorced in the future
like I wonder if there's going to be an
increase of like people once the kids
are out of the house getting divorced
because it's like 50 stay married but
how do they calculate that
oh god well yeah this is this is the
thing is we tend to focus a lot on 45.5
divorce
but that would imply oh well then over
half the marriages are working out well
not when you look at the percentage of
marriages that are sexualists not when
you look at the ones that seem to be
fractious or abusive or marriage is only
in name
um but still there there's a good a good
chunk of society that actually manage
even in this day and age to have
highly successful supportive marriages
yeah my are Muslim
um I'm happy to say so uh it's it's
it'll be interesting to see what happens
in the Next Generation with people
splitting up after the kids are getting
out of the house but that doesn't seem
to be the Benchmark people don't seem to
be waiting that long married couples uh
seem to wait a couple of years after
they have the kids and then uh you know
80 of the time alone are splitting so
they're not even waiting for the kids to
come of age
um it seems like the only goal they care
about is is uh having the kid and then
then the marriage itself is dispensable
yeah I guess my bigger question is I
just wonder what percent of marriage is
like if 10 people get married what what
percent come out okay like what percent
you know come out not sexless not you
know not only together in name like what
what's someone in 2023 shot of you know
actually doing the thing
well I mean in 2023 uh 15 your life is
going to get destroyed
um as for till death do you part
I mean allowing for the fact that it's
too early to actually have statistics
because it takes a while for for a
marriage to be a happy ending because of
course it requires actual expiry uh for
both groom and bride
um
let's say a third maybe maybe a quarter
maybe a third to a quarter in the
millennial and Zoomer generation maybe
uh and that's that's the people who of
those two generations that are actually
getting married and not a lot of us are
so and you know but even throw in the
people who are not getting married but
are cohab
right uh even then maybe a third maybe a
quarter it's actually working out long
term and most of those marriages aren't
happening and there's their 20s that
most of those marriages are happening
late 30s early 40s sometimes a second
marriage
um where basically you're finding
someone uh uh and clinging to them like
Grim death so you don't wind up alone
you know you're two broken people at
that point just just living up eeking
out the rest of their lives
um as opposed to something more
conventional
um with you know matrimony mid late 20s
um and and children so the the
statistics also get thrown off by uh
those who are World weary and get
married
really so that all so the majority are
you wait hold on I want to make sure I
got this right so the majority of the
happy one like are the ones that are on
paper happy are or a good chunk are from
getting married in their you said mid to
late 30s and it's like holding on for
dear life
uh well it's difficult to tell again
because we're talking success The
Benchmark of success here is till death
to be part so we're talking angels it's
too soon to give you like hard and fast
statistics but
um
it seems to be an increasing Trend that
people are treating marriage as a sort
of therapy tool where they they've
gotten knocked around uh in their 20s
and 30s and suddenly uh they're
salvaging what's left of their life and
and finding a stable partner thereafter
as for the percentage I could not say
it's it's not the majority
um I would I would hesitate to say it's
even more than a third it's it's
certainly not half of them but an
increasing amount of people that's what
they're using marriage for rather than a
something that that happens young and
you do for procreation
um okay tell me about
fertility like women are lied to about
fertility tell me
I know that was one of the things you
said to me like women are told that we
can get IVF in our 30s
oh yeah um I wish I had the statistics
in front of me but it is a harrowing a
failure rate
um and and so I don't have the
statistics in front of me but by all
means I invite people listening to look
it up online
um they've got the success rate uh just
invert the percentages
um for various age brackets uh it's it
becomes very rapidly Grim after age 30.
like it's not even great at 30.
um and uh at post 35 like
you're lucky if you get a kid
out of it and and uh Post 40 you know
when you're you're next to menopause
forget about it
very lucky you're increasingly playing
the lottery after 30 which is is starter
it's it's startling when you consider
the average age I think in the US at
least where women have the first child
is uh last time I checked was 29. so
you're already starting when when the
game is nearly over
you know and then no you can't fall back
on on fertility treatments necessarily
because the failure rate is high and the
expenses prohibited
so
wow
the average age of first child is 29. I
didn't know that it's getting later and
it varies from country to Country so
don't it might be depending on the state
you look up and what country it might be
27 it might be 28 but uh and then men
it's like 30 31 32. wow well
um thank you so much for coming on
honestly um I feel like I learned so
much every time I talk to you I try to
keep up
oh then it's it's uh it's a pleasure
yeah no I definitely I have another
interview coming up but um I definitely
want to bring you back to talk about
some of these topics so in depth because
freaking you you know so much it's so
obvious you like know so much you know
we covered sort of a very broad swath of
things off the top of my head but
absolutely
um if there's any specific topics you
want me to drill down to I can come here
equipped with all my stats and
everything yeah
okay no we're definitely going to do
that in the future um tell the people
where they can find your book
okay uh the uh Sex book sets two million
years of procreation and Recreation will
be available from Black Ink books in
October 2023 uh I'm I've given your pa
um a link for pre-order and if you want
to buy my current book uh it's about in
uh Australia UK and we'll be out in the
United States on May 2nd
um at all good booksellers
um and I'll also give a link for uh the
the uh
um us version of the book I'll give you
the Barnes and Noble one I think there
might be a discount
okay guys
um well thank you so much for coming
guys make sure you like the video on
your way out
um subscribe to the channel make sure
you ring that notification bell all
right and make sure you go buy his book
I started look it I don't want a free
time but I did start like I did start
reading it and it's actually really
interesting because he breaks it down
like by period
um he even has a whole chapter on like
the first like orgasm I was like what
yeah I know he's laughing so um anyways
guys make sure you go check out his book
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time